[Aplausos]
a lo largo de la historia la humanidad
ha hecho cosas increíbles hemos
evolucionado nos hemos asentado en
civilizaciones
hemos creado herramientas increíbles
como la computadora como el teléfono
móvil hemos hecho cosas asombrosas
inventamos el internet y ahora estamos
en una era en la que estamos súper cerca
de casi cualquier persona en el mundo a
unos cuantos clics
estamos viviendo una era digital una era
en la que muchas cosas hace algunos ayer
es solo eran ciencia ficción pero hoy
son una realidad
y la inteligencia artificial es un caso
muy interesante
para esto quiero contextualizar contando
una breve historia
en general un científico observa la
naturaleza
observa algún fenómeno e intenta
describir ese fenómeno entonces lo que
sucede es que plantea una hipótesis
diseñó un experimento y a través de este
experimento busca acreditar esta
hipótesis o totalmente rechazarla y tal
vez cambiarla en las ciencias
computacionales
este método científico no es una
excepción y algo muy interesante sucede
porque cuando en su momento en la
historia los neurocientíficos estudiaban
cómo funcionaba el comportamiento de las
células en el cerebro cuando se concibió
por primera vez el concepto formal de lo
que era un neurona como célula primaria
que transmite información en el cerebro
gente que hacía cómputo dijo oye si
queremos hacer inteligencia artificial
por qué no basarnos en un comportamiento
natural algo real
y fue en esta historia que se
desarrollaron parte de los de los
primeros modelos de inteligencia
artificial en aquel entonces había
muchos otros modelos en la actualidad
hay muchos otros modelos pero sí ha
habido un boom en estos últimos años ha
sido por la presencia y la capacidad de
procesamiento que tienen modelos basados
en redes neuronales artificiales y al
final estos modelos no son otra cosa más
que conceptualización la abstracción de
cómo funciona una neurona en el sentido
de que al hacer sinapsis con otra
neurona transmite información esta
operación de sinapsis a nivel
computacional matemático
no es otra cosa más que operaciones que
quizás sean fáciles quizás sean más
complejas dependiendo del problema que
se quiera resolver
pero pum
las redes neuronales como modelo de
inteligencia artificial han sido otra de
las grandes hazañas de la humanidad
en fin seguramente nos estamos
preguntando cuál es el potencial de
estas cosas y es que en la actualidad
vivimos día a día con inteligencia
artificial que a veces pasa
imperceptible
pero déjenme aterrizar un poco las cosas
seguramente utilizarán su red social
favorita y sucederá que suben una
fotografía donde tal vez aparezcan
ustedes o sus amigos y esta red social
favorita curiosamente tiene la capacidad
de usar algoritmos inteligentes para uno
detectar rostros de personas en imágenes
y dos identificar cada uno de estos
rostros en las imágenes y esto es un
ejemplo de día a día en el que nosotros
somos usuarios de modelos de
inteligencia artificial sucederá lo
mismo con su aplicación favorita para
saber qué canción es la que está sonando
en fin
tal vez pensemos que este tipo de
modelos solo puede ser desarrollado por
grandes compañías por gente que sea muy
docta y se dedique a investigación
pero bueno tengo un ejemplo un poco más
aterrizado y para este ejemplo les voy a
pedir que presten particular atención en
los rostros de las personas que
aparecieran en este vídeo
tal vez no se perciba tanto pero déjenme
comentarles un poco qué es lo que está
sucediendo
en la vista del lado izquierdo tenemos
un conjunto parte de senos de una
película
relativamente reciente
en la parte central tenemos las mismas
escenas pero hay un cambio particular
que está sucediendo en el rostro de esta
persona y del lado último más a su
derecha
hasta mi izquierda
vemos que hay un mapeo algo que está
sucediendo es que
este vídeo fue procesado
me tomo alrededor de cinco horas armar
un modelo basado en una red neuronal
profunda que se encargará de sustituir
la cara de este actor de peter parker
justamente por mi cara entonces mis
sueños en realidad ya fui spider-man
este puede ser un caso muy simple en el
que entra en un modelo de inteligencia
artificial para sustituir mi cara pero
más allá de esto podemos pensar en en
ciertas implicaciones y esto va un poco
ligado a lo que comienza a suceder en la
actualidad
en este caso yo sustituí mi cara pero
imaginemos que existe la grabación de un
vídeo en donde alguien está haciendo
cualquier acto ilícito
y por algún motivo yo decido utilizar un
modelo para sustituir la cara de otra
persona e inculpar a esta persona
entonces estamos ya metiéndonos en temas
que comienzan a volverse más fuertes no
llegamos a un punto en la actualidad en
el que hace falta cierto rigor ético
respecto a lo que está sucediendo en
temas de inteligencia artificial y hay
personas que se encuentran trabajando en
estos momentos
por decidir qué sucede si debe haber
alguna ley que rija todo este tipo de
desarrollos y demás
por otra parte también está el lado
positivo pero hasta este punto podemos
llegar a una bifurcación que quizás en
sus pensamientos llegaron a la
conclusión de que tener inteligencia
artificial puede ser algo peligroso
para hacer cosas ilícitas
algo que sucede es que grandes
personalidades con mucha presencia en el
mundo han llegado a conclusiones
similares
y la verdad es que tienden a estar a
veces en ciertos extremos por una parte
hay quien dice
la guía en los próximos cinco o diez
años realmente va a ofrecer soluciones
que mejoren la calidad de vida de la
humanidad
y en su contraparte otras personas dirán
realmente la inteligencia artificial es
un riesgo fundamental de la humanidad
totalmente extremista
pues bueno si me lo preguntaron a mí
realmente
creo que debería haber un punto medio en
el que obviamente si hay que tener
consideración para evitar algo como esto
ya saben un mundo post-apocalíptico como
terminator
darnos cuenta de que hay más allá
de solo fijarnos en en lo negativo y las
malas aplicaciones un caso positivo
es esto sabemos que actualmente estamos
viviendo una crisis en la que hay una
epidemia de coronavirus a nivel global
entonces investigadores alrededor del
mundo están desarrollando modelos de
inteligencia artificial que en cierto
sentido lo que hacen es comprender el
comportamiento de esta enfermedad a lo
largo del tiempo y pueden realizar
predicciones respecto a la propagación
posible de esta epidemia
en lo particular a mí me gustaría
compartirles
algo con lo que yo he estado trabajando
antes de llegar al clímax y a la idea
que les quiero transmitir en esta breve
charla
llevo un par de años trabajando
específicamente con modelos de
inteligencia artificial enfocados a
tratar personas en particular
expresiones faciales para poder
clasificar emociones y pensarán esto
para que pues sucede que hay muchas
personas que pueden llegar a tener algún
padecimiento mental
llámese a alguna psicopatología en
específico o simplemente alguna crisis
psicológica en la que en su mayoría la
atención brindada consta de terapias de
acompañamiento
como parte del tratamiento
este tipo de sistemas busca ser un
complemento que aproveche este tipo de
tecnologías para sacar al máximo el
potencial que tiene la humanidad y con
esto volvemos a algo que mencionaba una
de estas dos personas con gran presencia
por una parte de la humanidad si puede
ser algo que nos concierne como
humanidad
si no se toma como algo serio
pero por otra parte
puede ser una herramienta que habilite
un futuro tecnológico lleno de
posibilidades que nos ayuden a seguir
evolucionando como humanidad
les comparto un pequeño ejemplo de este
modelo que les comento que he estado
trabajando
y para esto les voy platicando un poco
que en realidad
lo que sucede es que a partir de un
modelo a partir de muchos datos de
personas se construye una red neuronal
profunda que es capaz de trabajar y
detectar micro expresiones faciales esto
es cualquier
rasgo físico en el rostro de una persona
que pueda caracterizar una emoción y hay
demasiado estudio sobre esto lo
interesante
viene cuando íntegras una tecnología que
sea capaz de complementar este
conocimiento humano y aplicarlo para
automatizar un proceso y complementar
una solución entonces aquí les comparto
que está funcionando la cámara de mi
computadora la idea es que tengo una
gráfica en tiempo real y si el sistema
funciona de manera correcta debería ser
capaz de detectar mi rostro y en tiempo
real evaluar y decir qué emociones estoy
sintiendo
y con esto
vuelvo al tema
en el que lo que tal vez hace mucho
tiempo sonaba como ciencia ficción
hoy comienza a ser una realidad
y a través de un proyecto como éste
buscamos complementar para seguir
creciendo como humanidad
ahora
lo que yo les quiero transmitir a
ustedes es lo siguiente y este es un
breve ejercicio que pueden realizar esta
noche o todas las noches que quieran
transmitírselo a sus hijos y demás es un
ejercicio reflexivo y vamos a hablar de
futuro y no de este futuro de
terminators y esas cosas sino otro tipo
de futuros
pensando lo siguiente
imaginemos cómo llegará a ser el futuro
puede ser que en un futuro haya coches
voladores
puede ser que haya amas de casa que sean
robots y se encarguen de de hacer
labores domésticas o amos de casa y que
se encarguen de hacer de comer pensando
en que mi papá cocina riquísimo por
cierto
en fin el futuro es un devenir que
además es un abanico de posibilidades
pensemos en cosas positivas
en este futuro imaginemos cosas útiles
imaginemos que tal vez podremos tener un
sistema inteligente en casa que sea
capaz de diagnosticar si en un futuro
esperemos o muy lejano exista esta
tecnología esperemos y lejano para
cuando yo tenga hijos en el supuesto de
que yo tenga a mi hijo y que mi hijo
esté enfermo que este sistema me diga
tiene tal cosa deberías darle esto en
fin el futuro lo podemos imaginar como
sea
pero mi pregunta hacia ustedes es
qué es lo que como humanidad estamos
haciendo por alcanzar ese futuro que nos
gustaría ver
y aquí es donde la pregunta se torna
interesante porque
al final nosotros formamos parte de esta
sociedad de esta humanidad
y formamos parte de esta evolución que
va creciendo día a día entonces si
nosotros no estamos contribuyendo va a
ser muy difícil alcanzar este futuro y
al menos en mi caso
yo no quiero estar esperando a que
alguien más esté contribuyendo sino yo
como parte de esta humanidad contribuir
y llegar a tener un mejor futuro gracias
[Aplausos]